going back to the idea for Space Command
so how long have you actually been
working on it since the very beginning
like the idea in Texas like 1832 it was
not via the initial idea for Space
Command came about in 2012 Oh
and year so it was a few years and but
but it was really in germinating in my
head for a long long time because again
I wanted to create a hopeful vision of
the future I wanted to do for the modern
audience what Star Trek had done for me
as a kid and so I really was starting to
put the pieces together and also I was
collecting actors you know as in my
career in television I was doing working
on a lot of science fiction shows and
gathering a lot of actors but I really
wanted to work with again and write
roles for and you know I recently wrote
a book with Guillermo del Toro and I am
I won the Saturn Award a couple years
ago and I saw this amazing guy in this
Victorian coat was tall thin guy really
remarkable looking I went up to him - at
SAG Awards to congratulate him on book
the coat and how he looked and it was an
actor named Doug Jones and Doug is and
pretty much everything Guillermo does he
played pan and Pan's Labyrinth and Abe
Sapien and Hellboy he's in the strain
and he's in just pretty much everything
crimson peak and he's been in tons of
other things he's the lead alien and
falling skies so we had lunch really hit
it off and as I told him I was going to
write a role for him a lead and that's
what we did in Space Command and so so
the crowdfunding campaign was in 2012
and that and that along with his the
investment shares that we sold and her
still she is continuing to sell gave us
the money to open our own studio and
then as I said I mention I wrote you
know the first 8 hours of the show and
outlet hours 9 through 12 and Elena and
I have them actually co-writing on this
and and so that was this big tapestry
this great big canvas and and so just
kind of grew and grew as I started to
know who the characters were and what
those story was I knew I wanted to tell
a multi-generational story and I wanted
to have a very multi national
multi-ethnic multiracial cast so our
actors are wise in black and Asian and
Latino and
actors confirm Venezuela and Pakistan
and Sri Lanka all around the world and
and I cast many famous actors but we
also had a Talent Search or anywhere
anyone anywhere in the world could
download the audition scenes and
audition for two of our leads and we got
7,000 enquiries in 1,200 videos we also
ended up casting six actors from those
from those auditions and including lakh
two of our leads and from them from my
own Ling from New York from Iowa from
there all over the place and so Space
Command kind of came together in bits
and pieces
and still it still comes it comes it's
funny because once you start shooting
something the actors and their
performances and the chemistry between
them also is something that starts to
alter your vision you start it becomes a
dialogue between you and them if you if
you do it well and answer then you say
over here's an interesting way of doing
it here's an interesting way of of
having it pay off
also because we jump back and forth over
five generations of our of our
characters there's four families and we
see the action and reaction we go back
and forth between that over one hundred
fifteen year period and so so for
instance the first two our story takes
place at one point sixty years from now
and then the second - our story takes
place three years after that and then at
various points were jumping 90 years
later and coming back so it's really
this very interesting tapestry that we
get to see so I really love that I
haven't seen that before I haven't seen
anyone else do that
and very to see actors develop an owner
role yes and that definitely does mold
and usually deepen you know you're
starting to rewrite and throw in extra
scenes because they themselves and just
really step deeply into the character
you know and things come alive that you
hadn't seen you know relationships come
alive but you hadn't seen and so the the
talent hunt was amazing these are
brilliant acting all over the world
Wilma castex people but we would have
liked to have cast a lot more they just
didn't quite fit the role as well but
there were fine actors all over the
country and so that was fun it was fun
the world all around the world and I was
really fine with Jo
who is a wonderful actor but he usually
is almost like a mind because he plays
creatures right but he has this
stunningly beautiful man and and so in
this we finally get to see him and we
get to see what reality is extremely
delicate it is very sensitive actor
aghast and so it's grand to being able
to you know give him that station let
the people but people see what a what a
consummate actually is with very little
makeup well there's an interesting thing
that happened on set we were shooting
the first chunk with shots basically and
in various chunks because we have a
lower budget then a studio film would
have us to our TV show we had to be very
clever in how we utilized our money so
it was used effectively so we shot four
days of the first two-hour story and
then came back several months later on
some of the other sets we built and shot
the rest of it and so the first several
days we were shooting all of Jones's
scenes and me referral and and bill
money and so forth there was a lot of
dialogue to cover we were shooting eight
to twelve pages a day and Doug was Doug
Jones was very nervous about being able
to remember all the lines even with all
of our actors we had other actors with
them to just run the lines when they
weren't on you know when we were
shooting or they were just just what
camera to throw the line we said look we
can edit we can edit never worry about
dropping a line because it will be
thrown right back and I can cut into it
and well when we stop making them
nervous when they weren't nervous about
it
they usually remembered their line we're
just nerves that would send them up but
what I said that Doug was I said because
he was nervous about getting lines and
doing all the lines and I said look we
as Elaine said we can we can pick it up
it's not about the lines I said we're
here for one purpose and one purpose
only I said you have an amazing soul and
our our job here is to show the audience
your soul and that's all we're here to
do and so don't worry about the lines
and the irony was from now on he never
blew a line not once and so he was able
to relax but he did a phenomenal job his
performance is terrific and we're going
to continue on going to utilize his
character because we have two viewpoint
characters what I call viewpoint
characters over 150 years because most
the characters grow old an age and die
and so forth they have children and
grandchildren and great-grandchildren
but but Doug Jones is a synthetic a
synthetic human he's an Android
replicant so he covers the entire 150
years as a viewpoint character and me
referral implies a human but she's been
genetically altered where she's very
hard to kill she's practically immortal
and so again she'll be another viewpoint
character over that time frame and and
her character's also her character as a
daughter who hasn't been genetically
altered so she ages in the normal time
frame but and mirrors also in a gay
marriage she's married to a woman
because again I want the world of Space
Command to match the world I live in and
it was very interesting with Sally Ride
Sally Ride was the first American female
astronaut and was only when she died
that they mentioned her longtime
companion and I said well why didn't
everyone know that she was gay
I mean why where they where they gave
women in science fiction where the game
women in science and I think it's very
important that we know that that all
these people that the world is what the
world is that it's inclusive and I want
Space Command to be inclusive and so so
that was that was very fun to write that
and have that in Space Command as well
we have Muslim characters we have all
sorts of characters and again to present
the commonality of humanity so that so
we don't see people as the other we see
them as ourselves
you